I gotta make you look good I don't been
through this is real life I cannot
pretend to 14 year old rapper Flo Jay
impressing the judges on America's Got
Talent
her father was murdered before she was
born now she's writing music about her
story and perseverance never let him
tell you what you can't do because I
have made it this far I can't lose
Raja's audition was pure gold literally
yes judge Chris Hardwick especially
loved it you are not given a chance to
have a relationship with your father you
were not given a chance then and I want
to make sure you get a chance now don't
you my friend Flo Jay came to the et
Studios in June before her big golden
buzzer moment how much has your life
changed since the audition my life has
changed a crazy like I get a lot of
Instagram deals they're like your song
really inspired me you know a lot of
people in there they're like in boxing
they're like my dad died too not the
same way but you know it still affects
me and when I listen to your song and
make me feel better so you know just to
know that I'm like inspiring people and
making them feel better through one song
it it makes me feel like really good
[Music]